[Music]
in Google detective news submitted by
2020s and 3 months holy Christmas season
is in one month that election season
tease huh it's election year it's
election year unfortunate already we're
gonna be in the twenty that's pretty
crazy in the twenty and our cars can fly
can I get a [ __ ] filter that just
gets rid of all election news on my
phone listen someone actually invented a
chrome expect Chrome extension to get
rid of all Kardashian news we do that
for pub just need it
I need that that's to I want to be blind
for all my stupid [ __ ] friends posts
constantly if you like politics politics
news never stop god no no exactly the
campaign never stop you can mute them oh
yeah I should actually figure out a wish
it would be selective when it's like
about that that's what I mean to it but
then I get to still be oh no if they're
posting that much about politics and
stuff I don't know I don't care I know
some people let it consume their lives
I'm like you're so long and boring okay
but so funny though I follow extreme
left people extreme right people and
feminist people and they make me all
that well me I'm with you but some
people take it to the [ __ ] okay all
right yeah look of you do this in my
life with all I see like I was giving
him you can't do that confusing and
Casey was like doing like a potty dance
over there he's like he's a little bit
you know I apologize that was I was
adding to what he was saying and you
accept her apology yes thank you
she's like we'll do the video later
we'll do it later
[ __ ] images from Google Earth help
solve a 22 year old cold case of a
missing man
oh when technology saves her life is he
dead
well was he addict was he at a campsite
when technology closes the case when
technology finds the dead victim yeah
yeah so what happened here is those this
missing man back in 1997 this 40 year
old named William bolt he went missing
after going to a nightclub and he called
his girlfriend and said he was on his
way home but he never made it home but
22 years later this guy was on google
satellite or Google Maps looking at
satellite images of his old neighborhood
because he was just curious and he was
kind of like going through it and he
realized that there was something weird
and this wouldn't like a body of water
near the neighborhood Oh lots of those
guys she was like what what is that so
then he ended up contacting someone that
lives nearby and then they told he asked
him he wait sorry yeah so then the guy
who found this on Google Images
he ended up can't lose it again so then
the guy ended up contacting the current
homeowner and asked him to use a drone
to confirm whether it was a car because
that what's a drone in the pond
oh my Daly's lying around like hey you
don't know me use your [ __ ] drone
we're gonna solve the murder just [ __ ]
out and then it made me think like I
don't know like current you know hug
back in the day you'd have like a house
phone I'm like how do you contact the
current woman right but anyway he's
legit legit big yellow pages so then the
guy did and he did find out that it was
a white car and so he called the
sheriff's office so he did have a drone
deputies later found
so so then they ended up finding out
that there were skeletal remains inside
of the car and they did a DNA testing so
it's just a skeleton like at a lab you
know like with clothes on dudes crazy
that's for to do do you think there's
Gators and [ __ ] no don't reuse the
inside the car though how are they gonna
get in the car very afraid of Gators
that I believe that they could get into
a car these minute flaw Rideau many
times you seen some [ __ ] seen some
[ __ ] Gators Hey are you like double
lock in the hotel room and then you're
like Nicky's a [ __ ] you doing like
Gators [ __ ] like why we're on the third
floor were you go past a second I know
this for a fact
can't get in the elevator at least hey
kid [ __ ] crying fences now did you
know that Gators yeah before I no no you
not [ __ ] long their noses are in
their arms it's good they do it sideways
they learned yeah they go sideways like
this they go like that and then they
climb sideways and then they go like
that I'm not even kidding they learned
how to [ __ ] do this recently it's
just like how monkeys just entered the
Bronze Age because they just started
using tools and [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] Gators
learn how to climb that they put the
[ __ ] grass and then they go mmm
and then they eat the ads mm-hmm wait
Gators no monkey monkeys we're on the
monkeys the monkeys
[Laughter]
they'll be funny
the show moves quick deal little gainer
with his hand like this special little
[ __ ] it's because they're so short
you yeah
I'm trying to load up this photo but
he's right they are climbing a [ __ ]
fuzzy show it to the people I want to
see that [ __ ] no I saw it in your eyes
the only reason I was at NASA and I saw
a [ __ ] Gator on the lawn but like I
saw in the cockpit piloting that [ __ ]
to colonize the moon
[Laughter]
okay wait show to the people shoot the
black thing oh that's how they climb
it's okay we'll take your word
it's a gator climbing a ladder in the
dark you can kind of see it here fine
Carmencita
there it is I saw it oh my god oh it's a
fence okay they're learning they're
learning if I saw that I would just run
towards the fence they kick that Gator
in the belly yep I'm gonna run towards
danger well Chloe hasn't climbed don't
worry at all the climb over kill the
smart because you'll fall backwards like
this and you'll be able to spin too what
you can fly I put a cockroach on the
back one time and all that for her to do
this anyway just like a gator so I can't
load the stupid photo so let me show you
the Google Earth photo oh yeah that's a
straight car do you notice that [ __ ]
yeah they really paid attention well at
least they know who's in there because
they did the National Missing Persons
thing DNA thing and they figured out who
it was which was you got ran off the
road huh well see picture what does guy
look like he might've been driving at
night and just didn't know where does
all that looked like somebody's backyard
though he was drawn yeah maybe I'm
driving true and no one saw him from a
nightclub ah that just happened
somewhere else
I don't know [ __ ] where it was like
well one of those states with tons of
lakes and [ __ ] same kind of [ __ ] just
have this again
maybe maybe the Ozarks or some [ __ ] so
somebody's drunk like just drove off no
they they it was a missing-persons case
it's same kind of [ __ ] happened where
they found the car like in the water
like off of an anonymous tip and then
yeah
yeah same [ __ ] and the lady was
perfectly intact in there just like and
it solved like a 30-year old cold case
in 30 years you're so bad for the cops I
got to pull it out because it smells
like [ __ ] in there there's thing it was
heavily calcified okay feel like
everything's been eating away at that
point though what the pilots outfit was
it had on like you see the job why came
out of a Halloween party well cause it
you're questioning Joe's brain he's
leaving and you think a Halloween party
no it's because he was going to work cuz
I didn't know what night club leaving a
nightclub huh he was leaving a nightclub
in a Halloween party at the nightclub
gee Jesus no no but but I was thinking
that he was going to work as a pilot he
made up your own say yes because I
needed to know what kind of job he had
oh so he was like yeah he was a pilot
thank God he didn't get no [ __ ] plane
that is the real nice right Jesus I
could thinking about this I mean he was
coming home from cheating on his wife no
so I was thinking this wasn't in
November of 97 he was 40 years old he
was born in the fifties they could have
been the same about that she graduated
my mom graduated high school in Sisson I
got you I got you I got you
a wheat is kind of good what we I can't
get along with weed man weed [ __ ] with
me what happens to you you get scared
slow I get slow and I don't like the
idea yeah
that's why I don't really like weed
either yeah I like that I like that I
get slow you like that you think hear my
thoughts now I'm in a constant fog yeah
no I like it I can think clearly you
know I'm like my brains not going back
I'm gonna be constant like this oh you
say don't you think that you're gonna
like just be like this forever only
I know there's I know a lot of people
who did weed too long or any they slowed
down big time yeah but you're gonna be
doing a lot like I'm not long as I'm at
a time I know I got no hate for weed
people out there I love it sounds like
you do well no no but I don't I swear
and I love are you hating on them I love
all the libertarian weed people out
there very valuable
that's [ __ ] condescending a [ __ ] I
ever heard it why us cuz they're slower
I don't mean it like that
well but they probably can't catch up
with where I'm at I love the weed people
I know I just I just I just slow down
and I get paranoid about me get sleepy I
get paranoid I don't I and I get sleepy
you come on the cocaine does you like
the fast paced life never try to put
ahead adderall and heard that similar
adderall is more like mad and
amphetamines right dude there's a you
can google this there's a show called
Dyna Club season two Dino Yacht Club
okay it's a cartoon show that I wrote on
adderall it's a [ __ ] it doesn't do many
good I'm just saying you could go watch
a man on after all had his thoughts
cuz he watched diamond Hot Club season 2
where a bunch of dinosaurs work for
Ronald Reagan in the 1980s they were his
strike team whenever he had a global
crisis I'm [ __ ] sold on this so far
and they used and they fly f-16 or f-14
Tomcats and that sounds dope it's all
missions for him well if adderall can
help you become like creative why don't
we all take it
maybe you should maybe we should but
when but when I we watched it recently I
was like wow this is just like a big
giant Alzheimer's go
[Music]